basically the the central argument of
the book is that there was a
transformation in popular and medical
and psychiatric understandings of
schizophrenia that happened in the 1960s
in relation to certain responses
different kinds of responses to the
civil rights era and to the tensions of
the civil rights movement at the time
and I show pretty pretty directly how
civil rights politics civil rights
anxieties other kinds of things really
shaped our understanding of insanity in
this country and one part of that
narrative is that as I was mentioning
before we we developed at that time and
a belief that schizophrenia was an
illness that was increasingly marked by
anger hostility projection and even
though that's not part of the diagnosis
anymore
you see the origin in the 1960s of a set
of stigmatization Ziff people with with
schizophrenia in particular as being
violent that rose throughout the latter
half of the 20th century even after they
were associated with race all of a
sudden this initially this was a
category that was applied to these angry
protesting african-american men but you
see a broadening of this stigma to the
point where it came to apply to all
persons who suffered from schizophrenia
and there are great research studies
that actually come from
vielen and linked to sociologists here
at Columbia that show that even though
Americans have actually grown more
accepting of particular mental illnesses
stigma against depression obsessive
compulsive disorder anxiety have all
gone down over the last 50 years
stigma against schizophrenia
particularly as being violent has risen
over this same time period and I think
this history tells us tells us why so
one after effect of this period is
stigma of skit against schizophrenia is
being violent a second thing we see in
in the aftermath of this history is a
literature that's called the
misdiagnosis or over diagnosis of
schizophrenia in minority population
particularly black men a third area
which I can talk about in a bit if you
wish is the criminalization of mental
illness and this assumption that people
with schizophrenia are threats to the
state in a certain kind of way but
there's a flip side to the story as well
which is that schizophrenia was also a
metaphor a term a linguistic usage that
was taken up within civil rights
discourse itself I have a few chapters
where I talk about how schizophrenia
became a term that Martin Luther King
used in seven or eight of his main
sermons and in a bunch of his writings
and for King schizophrenia was an
illness that it actually wasn't an
illness what he said was there's
schizophrenia literally means split mind
and he said there's a split and in our
minds between good and evil dark and
light and what we need to do is choose
the path of nonviolent resistance
schizophrenia was also a term that was
taken up by leaders of the Nation of
Islam Black Power movement Malcolm X was
himself misdiagnosed with schizophrenia
in a CIA file I talked about that in the
book many of the leaders used
schizophrenia but what they said is it's
not an illness of the black mind instead
schizophrenia is a response to the
illness of white of white racism that
basically this is a justifiable means of
fighting back against white society and
it's interesting for me what I do is
track through that particular usage and
show how that didn't disappear and part
of the way I get to that is to look at
present-day uses of mental illness terms
in rap and hip-hop and popular cultural
music so toward the end of the book I do
a mini research project where I look at
lyrics databases and first what I do is
look for terms like depression or
depressed across all American popular
music and what you find is that terms
like depression and depressed show up in
the lyrics of people like America stick
Celine Dion Joni Mitchell the Eagles you
know kind of what you might call white
crooning
a certain kind of way I hate to
overgeneralize but it's very often
assumed to be a particular mood disorder
but if you go into the same databases
and you type in the word schizophrenic
schizophrenia or schizophrenic as I
talked about in the book on I list
references to over 200 rap or hip-hop
artists who the artists are actually
calling themselves schizophrenic Tupac
eat some other artists and basically
what they say is yeah I'm schizophrenic
and I'm violent and I'm hostile and I'm
a threat to your to you or to other
rappers or to the police or to the state
and you better get out of my way and
it's really interesting to say why would
this mental illness term show up in
hip-hop right and on one hand which I
think would be wrong is to say well
they're taking psychiatric usage in a
way and saying I'm just crazy or
something like that which is in part
true but for me it's actually saying
this history why what this usage is
actually coming from an earlier
tradition it's coming right out of the
usage in black power in the 1960s
basically saying hostility is a response
to structural violence and I'm going to
assume this identity as a way of
fighting back and so it's interesting
that it remains a protest identity and
in this particular form